un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis les chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
un an jour pour jour après l'assaut du
capitole à washington joe biden a livré
un discours solennel et d'une gravité
inédite depuis le fameux hall des
statuts le président américain estime
que son prédécesseur donald trump est
responsable de ce qu'il appelle une
insurrection armée pour john l'ancien
président américain a tenté d'empêcher
une transition pacifique du pouvoir le
locataire de la maison blanche promet de
se battre pour la démocratie
et le monde de plus en plus inquiet
c'est de la situation au kazakhstan
l'onu et de nombreux pays dont la france
appelle à des escalades de violence est
depuis plusieurs jours de nombreuses
manifestations ont lieu pour protester
contre l'augmentation du prix du gaz est
depuis le début de la contestation le
bilan est extrêmement lourd à plus de
700 blessés parmi les manifestants et 18
morts du côté des forces de sécurité
dont deux d'entre eux aurait été
décapité
[Musique]
et les non vaccinés reste des citoyens
démenti du premier ministre jean castex
ce matin pour tenter d'éteindre la
polémique liée aux propos controversés
d'emmanuel macron le président acquis et
souhaite je cite emmerder les
non-vaccinés jusqu'au bout et ce alors
que le pass vaccinale a été validée tôt
ce matin par les députés après trois
jours de débats houleux le texte doit
maintenant passer à par le sénat lundi
prochain
[Musique]
non
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
souvenez vous c'était il ya un an jour
pour jour ces scènes de violence au
capitole à washington
et des centaines de partisans de donald
trump ont tenté de prendre possession de
l'un des symboles de la démocratie
américaine
un an plus tard à la classe politique
américaine semble plus que jamais
divisée et c'est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
que joe biden a décidé de prendre la
parole depuis le célèbre hall des
statuts du capitole à pour un discours
on ne peut plus grave et solennel et le
président américain a n'hésite pas à
accuser donald trump des scènes de chaos
vu l'année dernière et estime que son
prédécesseur a tenté d'empêcher un
transfert pacifique du pouvoir
les détails avec notre correspondant à
washington tom abonnés
sur la forme la vice-présidente kamala
harris et le président joe biden ont
décidé de prononcer des discours depuis
l'intérieur du capitole à l'endroit
précis où des manifestants étaient
rassemblés il ya maintenant un an jour
pour jour kamala harris a d'abord pris
la parole en comparant cette journée du
6 janvier 2021 à des événements tels que
pearl harbor ou encore les attentats du
11 septembre 2001 elle a rendu hommage
aux forces de l'ordre qui sont
intervenues ce jour là et puis joe biden
a donc prononcé un discours et comme
attendu il s'en est pris à son
prédécesseur sans jamais le nommer
directement il a fait allusion à de très
nombreuses reprises à donald trump qu'il
tient pour responsables des violences
qui ont été commises le 6 janvier 2021
une attaque contre la démocratie de la
part d'un président qui a fait passer
ses intérêts avant ceux du peuple
américain voilà pour les principales
déclarations de joe biden le président
américain qui est a également répondu
aux accusations formulées depuis plus
d'un an par donald trump et ses soutiens
à savoir sur cette fraude électorale
supposée aux etats unis une façon dit
joe biden de masquer l'échec de donald
trump écoutez un extrait de son discours
où vous allez l'entendre il s'en prend
donc à son prédécesseur
pour la première fois dans l'histoire un
président n'a pas seulement perdu une
élection il a tenté d'empêcher un
transfert pacifique
pouvoir alors qu'une foule violente on
va hisser le capitole
à faire mais ils ont échoué ils ont
échoué et en ce jour de commémoration
nous devons nous assurer qu'une telle
attaque ne se reproduira jamais jamais
et voici la vérité l'ancien président
des états unis d'amérique a créé et
répondu en tissu de mensonges à propos
de l'élection de 2020 il l'a fait parce
qu'il privilégie le pouvoir aux
principes qui les considèrent que son
propre intérêt et plus important que
l'intérêt de son pays initié de
l'amérique
et puis c'était prévisible donald trump
a réagi à cette allocution quelques
minutes seulement après la fin du
discours prononcé par joe biden alors
donald trump devait initialement tenir
une conférence de presse ce jeudi mais
elle a été annulée et c'est donc par le
biais d'un communiqué écrit qu'il a
vivement critiqué les propos de joe
byden écouter joe biden a utilisé mon
nom pour tenter de diviser encore plus
l'amérique ce théâtre politique ne fait
que détourner l'attention du fait que
joe biden a complètement et totalement
échouer deux prises de position qui
illustrent que les divisions sont bel et
bien tenace aux états unis un an après
ces événements au capitole d'ailleurs
les différentes prises de parole des
principaux responsables politiques
américains illustre aussi cette fracture
les chefs de file des républicains au
congrès kevin mccarthy ou encore mitch
mcconnell ont dénoncé une exploitation
politique de cette journée par les
démocrates les démocrates qui de leur
côté ont organisé ce jeudi une journée
de commémoration avec notamment une
minute de silence et des prises de
parole autour de nancy pelosi la chef de
file des démocrates à la chambre des
représentants
la situation est grave voire dramatiques
au kazakhstan depuis plusieurs jours les
manifestations s'enchaînent contre la
hausse des prix de galles est sur place
les heurts entre forces de sécurité et
manifestants sont de plus en plus
fréquents un bilan provisoire plus d'un
millier de blessés des dizaines de
manifestants tués par la police et les
forces de sécurité comptent aussi au
moins 18 morts dont deux auraient été
décapité et 2000 personnes ont été
arrêtées ce matin dans la capitale et
l'onu et une grande partie de la
communauté internationale appelle à la
désescalade des violences moscou de son
côté a envoyé sur place une force de
maintien de la paix la correspondance en
russie de ma liste et serez
cette force de maintien de la paix
présentes au kazakhstan pour je cite une
durée illimitée afin de stabiliser de
normaliser la situation précise
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective
elle est constituée de soldats envoyés
par les autres pays membres de cette
organisation régionale que sont la
russie la biélorussie l'arménie le
tadjikistan et le kirghizistan
la mission principale des forces
collectif de maintien de la paix de
l'hôtesse et sera d'assurer la
protection des sites étatique et
militaire important est d'aider les
forces de l'ordre de la république du
kazakhstan à stabiliser la situation et
à assurer le retour de cette dernière
dans le cadre légal
de la part de la fédération de russie ce
sont des formations et des unités
militaires des troupes aéroportées qui
intégreront les forces collectives de
maintien de la paix de l'hôte et sc à
l'heure actuelle les forces russes du
contingent de maintien de la paix sont
transférés sur le territoire de la
république du kazakhstan à bord des
aéronefs de l'aviation de transport
militaire des forces aérospatiale russe
les unités avancées de ces forces ont
déjà commencé à exécuter les tâches
assignées ce mercredi le président
kazakhstanais avait demandé l'aide de
l'eau tsc pour contrer ce qu'ils
estiment être je cite une agression
extérieure commises par des gangs
terroristes
ces bandes terroristes sont en fait des
bandes internationale elles ont suivi
une formation approfondie à l'étranger
et leur attaque contre le kazakhstan
peut et doit être considérée et comme un
acte d'agression
de ce fait m'appuyant sur le traité de
sécurité collective
je me suis aujourd'hui tournés vers les
chefs de l'eau tsc ce pour leur demander
d'aider le kazakhstan à contrer cette
menace terroriste
en réalité il ne s'agit plus d'une
menace mais d'une atteinte à l'intégrité
territoriale de l'état et chose la plus
importante d'une attaque contre nos
citoyens qui me demande en tant que chef
de l'état de leur apporter une aide de
manière urgente
mon obligation constitutionnelle
consiste à veiller au bien-être à la
sécurité et à la tranquillité de nos
citoyens
par conséquent je considère qu'un appel
à nos partenaires de l'organisation du
traité de sécurité collective est tout à
fait approprié et opportun
je pense que le peuple du kazakhstan
soutiendra cette décision ensemble bien
sûr nous vaincrons
après plusieurs jours de manifestations
contre la hausse du prix du gaz les
anciennes républiques soviétiques
déplore d'ores et déjà des dizaines de
morts et plus d'un millier de blessés la
diplomatie russe a appelé à une
résolution pacifique des problèmes
actuels du kazakhstan dans le cadre
constitutionnel et juridique et non par
le biais des meutes et de violations de
la loi et au kazakhstan les
affrontements perdurent donc entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre les
précisions de notre correspondant sur
place igor jdanov
d'ailleurs dans la plus grande ville du
kazakhstan almaty l'ancienne capitale se
sont poursuivis dans la soirée
d'après les informations provenant du
terrain les forces de sécurité mènerait
une véritable opération
antiterroriste c'est du moins
l'expression utilisée avec pour objectif
de débarrasser les rues les
protestataires par débarrasser entendez
qu'elles sont disposées à recourir à
tous les moyens nécessaires
des vidéos par ailleurs montrent les
forces de sécurité annoncées via des
haut-parleurs quai sont prêtes à tirer à
vue sur toute personne qui déciderait de
rester dans les rues après le couvre-feu
le couvre feu débute ici à 23 heures
heure locale
et une crise au kazakhstan qui fait donc
réagir à travers le monde tour d'horizon
des réactions avec cyrielle bout et
la communauté internationale n'est pas
restée silencieuse face à la situation
au kazakhstan l'organisation des nations
unies s'est positionné en tant que
médiatrice en invoquant le droit de
manifester tout en préconisant le
respect de la non violence les gens ont
le droit de manifester pacifiquement et
de s'exprimer librement dans le même
temps les manifestants quel que soit
leur degré de colère ou de
mécontentement ne doivent pas recourir à
la violence contre les autres même son
de cloche du côté du royaume-uni et de
la france paris et londres s'accordent
sur l'importance du dialogue ils
appellent à la modération toutes les
parties impliquées dans cette crise pays
frontalier et allié du kazakhstan la
chine espère un retour rapide à la
normale
la chine et le kazakhstan sont des
voisins amis et des partenaires
stratégiques globaux permanent la chine
estime que ce qui se passe au kazakhstan
est une affaire intérieure du kazakhstan
crois que les autorités kazakhes peuvent
résoudre correctement le problème et
espère que la situation au kazakhstan
pourrait être stabilisé et que l'ordre
social pourra revenir à la normale dès
que possible des relations fortes entre
les deux pays marquées par un
anniversaire le 3 janvier 2022 les
présidents des deux pays ont célébré les
30 ans de leur étroite collaboration
et la cinquième vague touche fortement
les écoles les chiffres parlent d'eux
mêmes alors que les enfants n'ont fait
leur rentrée que lundi au total
75 mille élèves et 3000 membres du
personnel de tous bords sont isolés n
9202 classes sont actuellement tout
simplement fermé jean-michel bancaires
tentent de rassurer mais l'inquiétude
est grandissante pour les élèves mais
aussi pour les parents david khalifa
personne n'était pas reniée par le
variant omicron pas même les enseignants
au grand dam de jean michel blanquer
quelques 7 % d'entre eux manquent à
l'appel dans les établissements
scolaires le ministre de l'éducation
nationale fait des prévisions pour le
moins ambitieuse
est ce que je vais dire est que le mois
de janvier difficile bien sûr que non le
mois de janvier est difficile ils y
allaient situation que vous décrivez qui
sont bien réels et qui sont compliquées
est-ce que nous sommes démunis par
rapport aux problèmes de remplacement
c'est le principal sujet il est
impossible de dire quel sera le pic
d'absence mais ne devrait pas dépasser
normalement 15 % un taux bien en deçà de
celui avancé par le conseil scientifique
fin décembre l'organisme entrevoyait
qu'un tiers des enseignants au moins
pourraient être touchés par le commis 19
d'ici à la fin janvier de manière
directe en étant cas positifs ou
indirecte en étant en cas contactez le
nouveau protocole sanitaire mis en place
par l'exécutif est censé éviter cette
hécatombe encore faut-il réussir à le
suivre si un élève est testé positif
toute la classe doit faire un test puis
un autre deux jours plus tard et un
dernier après quatre jours un système
très compliqué à gérer pour les parents
d'élèves qui plus est révélé seulement
dimanche soir par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale depuis lundi la
rentrée des classes se déroule sous
tension voilà les enfants on doit
refaire des autotests ce que vous
imaginez des enfants de cinq six ans
quatre ans furent les autotests les
parents leur faire faire
et derrière des adaptations ce bonheur
nous allons faire cours dans des bocaux
vite dans des stalles qui sont souvent
tu as érable
avec parfois des températures assez
faible c'est très compliqué des masques
qui sont mal portée donc oui ce voit là
où ce n'est pas du tout confiants garder
les écoles ouvertes à tout prix c'est
l'argument principal de jean michel
blanquer mais sans enseignant c'est
plutôt compliqué pourquoi afficher temps
de confiance alors eh bien parce que le
ministre de l'éducation nationale estime
que les professeurs font partie des
catégories de professions les moins
touchés par l'épidémie ce qui était vrai
un temps bio mikron a changé la donne du
mois si l'on en croit l'exemple
britannique une étude du bureau des
statistiques nationales du royaume uni
un organisme gouvernemental paru mi
décembre indique elle exactement inverse
le coefficient de risque relatif d'être
testés positifs au co lead pour les
personnes travaillant dans le secteur de
l'éducation et de 0,38 un coefficient
supérieur à zéro indique une probabilité
accrue d'être testée positive par
rapport à la catégorie de référence en
l'occurrence les adultes actifs ne
travaillant pas dans l'enseignement des
chiffres qui n'ont rien de rassurant les
enseignants auraient souhaité une
fermeture des écoles ou une rentrée
décalée au vu de la vitesse de la
propagation du virus pour tenter
d'éteindre le feu jean castex a annoncé
la distribution de masques chirurgicaux
à tous les personnels enseignants le
premier ministre précise attendre un
avis des autorités sanitaires sur une
extension de l'utilisation des masques
ffp2 une réaction beaucoup trop tardive
aux yeux des syndicats
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais qui arrive
bien tard puisque l'épidémie a commencé
maintenant il ya près de deux ans deux
ans pour que enfin une décision soit
prise on nous explique que on ira
jusqu'à 15% d'absence mais on y est déjà
il fallait absolument prolonger ses
vacances en attendant que la vague
épidémique se calment l'a finalement on
entendait l'autre jour jean castex
tapait très violemment par ces mots sur
ceux qui propagent un l'épidémie cette
épidémie eh bien c'est ce sont les
décisions ministérielles qui
actuellement la faune galoper pour
reprendre les termes du premier ministre
s'obstiner à garder les écoles ouvertes
est une chose mais à quel prix telle est
la question
le projet de loi sur le post vaccinales
adopté en première lecture ce matin à
l'assemblée nationale devrait maintenant
être examiné au sénat dès la semaine
prochaine et des débats on sait qu'ils
ont été compliquées ces derniers jours
avec deux suspensions de séance qui font
donc perdre du temps par rapport au
calendrier initialement prévu par le
gouvernement un texte qui suscite
toujours de vives réactions au sein de
l'opposition regardez
cette nuit le pass vaccinale a été
adoptée par l'assemblée j'ai voté contre
non seulement il est inefficace inutile
et liberticide mais en plus jean castex
refusent de limiter son application dans
le temps présidente je supprimerai se
passe vaccinale
5h30 du matin la macro niveau tu le
passes vaccinale la république du qr
code le contrôle d'une partie de la
population par une autre la mise au ban
de millions de nos concitoyens 0 moyens
pour l'hôpital public
nous continuerons de nous être contre ce
texte dangereux et liberticide
5h40 du matin nous avons voté contre le
pass vaccinale qui a tout de même été
adopté j'ai pourtant la conviction que
ce texte ne permettra pas de mieux
protéger la santé des français mais
qu'il fait considérablement reculer leur
liberté
l'avenir nous le dira
l'hôpital n'a pas craqué quand il y
avait 100 % de non vaccinés et des
variants plus virulents il ne craquera
évidemment pas avec 10 % de non vaccinés
même s'ils ont fermé des lits ils le
savent bien ils mentent effrontément
explications contrôle social plus
corruption et les non vaccinés reste des
citoyens ce sont les mots de jean castex
ce matin pour tenter d'éteindre à la
polémique liée aux propos controversés
d'emmanuel macron prêt à je cite ont
merdé les non-vaccinés jusqu'au bout est
le premier ministre qui évoque également
la possible arrivée d'une quatrième dose
les israéliens l'ont fait après avis de
leurs autorités sanitaires dès que nos
autorités sanitaires auront dit oui
probablement pour les personnes les plus
fragiles si on dit on y va nous irons et
pour jean paul stahl professeur émérite
de maladies infectieuses à l'université
de grenoble la 4e doses seraient
nécessaires pour les plus vulnérables
ce qui compte c'est la protection contre
le virus tout le reste ce sont des ce
sont des arguties la quatrième dose
s'est jamais que refaire monter les
anticorps alors on n'a pour l'instant
pas de vaccin spécifique contre le les
nouveaux variants donc on est obligé de
jouer sur la quantité d'anticorps donc
elle sera la quantité d'anticorps
nécessaire ça je n'en sais rien tout ce
que je sais maintenant c'est que
la quatrième dose est sûrement
nécessaire pour protéger pleinement les
gens fragiles contre le variant au micro
alors un vaccin peut être un traitement
on a ça par exemple le traitement de la
rage c'est un vaccin qu'on a à peu près
85 % de la population qui est qui est
vacciné donc c'est plutôt bien on est
dans le dans le trio de tête européen en
matière de vaccination et c'est plutôt
une très très bonne chose et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que l'hôpital
n'explose part en ce moment
aurait mis ses pas de passât vaccinale
obligatoire pour tous c'est ce qu'a dit
aujourd'hui boris johnson qui a répété l
son attachement à une approche basée sur
le volontariat est le premier ministre
britannique a appelé cependant les non
vaccinés a passé le cap à un moment où
la pression s'accroît sur le système de
santé alors d'une visite dans un centre
de vaccination dans le centre de
l'angleterre est le chef du gouvernement
conservateur s'est aussi adressé aux
militants anti vaccins
quand
je veux juste tendre la main à tous ceux
qui n'ont pas encore été vaccinés et
leur dire que la vaccination est une
bonne chose mais je veux aussi dire aux
militants anti dax qui met ce charabia
sur les réseaux sociaux ce qu'ils ont
complètement thorn et vous ne m'avez pas
entendu dire cela avant mais je pense
qu'il est important que nous le fassions
désormais je veux une approche
volontaire face au vaccin dans ce pays
et nous allons garder une approche
volontaire je crois qu'il faut faire les
choses en travaillant ensemble et en
voyant l'importance vitale de la
vaccination
et nous avons des taux de vaccination
beaucoup plus élevé dans ce pays grâce à
cette approche volontaire dirigé par la
communauté c'est une chose merveilleuse
qu min il est pris
à moins d'un mois de la cérémonie
d'ouverture des jeux olympiques d'hiver
de pékin la chine continue de prôner la
politique du zéro qu'ovide lé
confinement se succèdent est le pays
envisage même la construction de centre
de quarantaine à grande échelle walid
bennani
l'impression d'une menace fantôme aux
conséquences effrayant mercredi les
autorités sanitaires de la ville de xian
pourtant voulu rassurer une population
confiné depuis le 23 décembre
plus de 10 millions de chinois sont
concernés
la tendance générale de l'épidémie est à
la baisse ce qui s'est avéré être le
résultat d mesures de prévention et de
contrôle précoce
qu'on
nous sommes cependant toujours dans la
période critique de la prévention et du
contrôle
un confinement strict depuis deux
semaines et des citoyens ravitailler en
produits de première nécessité par des
agents municipaux ces derniers sont
obligés de s'organiser avec minutie dans
un contexte de politique zéro
contamination selon les médias d'état la
ville de xian est en mesure d'effectuer
des prélèvements sur dix millions de
personnes 7 heures avec le variant
mikron la chine est plus que jamais
impliqué dans le triptyque tester tracé
isolé nous ne devons pas baisser notre
garde il est désormais certain qu mikron
est hautement transmissible
actuellement nous ne savons pas si son
taux de mortalité va augmenter mais nous
ne pouvons pas nous contenter de
regarder le taux de mortalité une
volonté qui ne devrait pas baisser dans
les prochaines semaines et dans les plus
grandes provinces et villes du pays
terminées les quarantaine dans des
hôtels et autres building place à la
construction de grands centres de santé
l'un d'entre eux est déjà en phase de
finalisation à gwangju
250 mille mètres carrés des dizaines de
bâtiments plus de 5000 chambres avec des
repas servis par des robots thermomètre
à intelligence artificielle
tous les voyageurs entrant dans la ville
seraient ainsi concernés aujourd'hui
seuls les citoyens chinois semblent
viser avec l'annulation de la quasi
totalité des vols internationaux depuis
le début de la pandémie des centres de
quarantaine qui pousse à l'image des
camps australien de son localisé près de
la ville de darwin au nord du pays
deux autres sont en construction à
l'extérieur de brisbane et de melbourne
et
après plusieurs interrogations elle
controverse au sujet de ces prochains
locataires le premier ministre
australien a confirmé que ces
installations ne concerneront pas les
non vaccinés
et on termine ce journal avec le reste
de l'actualité internationale en bref et
en images après l'erythrée hier le
ministre chinois des affaires étrangères
poursuit sa tournée africaine au kenya
aujourd'hui la prochaine étape les
comores demain la chine qui intensifie
son engagement en afrique est maintenant
le premier partenaire commercial du
continent
un palestinien tué par balle tout à
l'heure par l'armée israélienne à
naplouse en cisjordanie dans un
communiqué elle l'armée explique avoir
ouvert le feu après que ses soldats
était été visés par des tirs à d'après
les proches de la victime l'homme savait
que ses jours étaient comptés
et puis en france la cnil infligé une
amende record de 150 millions d'euros à
google est de 60 millions d'euros à
facebook d'après la commission nationale
de l'informatique et des libertés les
cookies géant des géants américains du
web elles ne respectent pas la loi
puisque les internautes n'ont pas la
possibilité d a vu les refuser à google
avait déjà dû s'acquitter d'une amende
de 100 millions d'euros à ce sujet
c'était attend décembre 2020
à trois mois du scrutin le dernier
sondage ifop fiducial pour lci dont
emmanuel macron en tête du premier tour
à 27% des intentions de vote le
président de vence les candidats aient
l'air à valérie pécresse du rn marine le
pen tout les deux faces s % eric zemmour
est à 13 5% elles selon la même enquête
le chef de l'état serait aussi donné
vainqueur au second tour malgré ses
propos polémiques au sujet des nouveaux
axes inné et même macron qui n'a
toujours pas annoncé sa candidature
écouter justement est le député bruno
bonnell au micro de david khelifa
c'est au président de décider quand il
se présenterait nous bien évidemment
nous soutenons toute idée de candidature
il dit dans cette interview qu'il en a
envie et qu'il a un projet donc on va on
va va regarder ce que ça veut dire qu'on
va le soutenir
ce quant à la majorité présidentielle
maintenant encore une fois il dit
quelque chose de très raisonnable il dit
au milieu d'une crise sanitaire je suis
président je suis à la gouverne de ce
pays je vais pas aller commencer à faire
des meetings électoraux où allait
commencer à avoir un programme électoral
élaboré pour le futur donc encore une
fois il fait la chose la plus importante
un chef il gère les priorités sa
priorité aujourd'hui c'est la santé des
français est notre priorité c'est le
pack vaccinale et plus les oppositions
continueront à jouer aux guignols dans
l'assemblée nationale avec des prétextes
pour délayer le temps de le mettre en
place et bien plus on prend on mettra
des français à risque et et on gérera
mal ses priorités évidemment une
campagne électorale c'est contre le
pouvoir en place et je comprends que vu
la faiblesse des idées des oppositions
ils n'ont rien d'autre à faire que des
grands gestes et et à vociférer dans
l'hémicycle ceci dit moi je les invite
surtout à proposer des vraies solutions
aux problèmes qu'ils évoquent moi je
veux bien des vraies solutions
alternatives sur la vaccination voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à vous
d'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité elle dans un peu plus de
trente minutes restez avec nous sur rt
france
me
[Musique]
vous
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'on nous trouve le
peuple c'était une volonté collectés
vous savez comme moi que des gants dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
politique il est clair que tout le monde
attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu livrant
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï